[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're joined by Joni and dibbens from
rare so we last for the game at e3 so
what's been going on since then updates
and news give it to me
indeed so yes so obviously III we showed
the magic of a going on adventures with
your friends in a pirate world shared
with other crews that are going on their
own adventures which was which was super
cool but we've been hard at work since
then and so coming to games got moving
in a completely new build and we are
going to be on the show floor having
Xbox and for the first time Windows 10
PC on the show for two there's a little
hidden message in there in there by
having Xbox and PC on the show floor
we're announcing cross play for the
first time so no asterisks no small
print is literally in our shared world
you are with people from multiple
devices so very excited about that
breaking down barriers but it is
genuinely a magical experience possibly
right it's sad when you send an email to
the whole team it was the first time I
played it I was at home or kind of on my
xbox and I joined in a couple of guys
from the the studio and they were
playing on PC and it was just seamless
why you couldn't even tell the
difference and and the fan I've never
done that before in a game and and it
was it was literally a magical
experience that and you know we have
people in our community that have been
playing on xbox or been playing on PC
and they've kind of made friends in the
forums and in the community but they've
yet to play you together and so for the
first time during games commit yourself
we flick the switch too much injustice
to our services team because they work
very hard but then won't actually came
to testing it it just worked and and
actually that allowed us to really focus
on the PC version so yeah we want to
know more come here with 21 by 9 with an
unlocked framerate and we've got that on
the show floor then we've also got 4k
running at 60 frames a second because we
knew that that was super important we
want to in early 2018 we want to bring
the PC game that players
and we felt that one of those
expectations is to be day and date right
is that we don't want the game to be
released after on PC like we've come
here to say the cross play the PC side
like it's just all together all in the
same day and get my little crew who
should I beat what kind of characters
what kind of people should be looking
for to make the best kind of pirate
squad goals the real mix right I don't
need someone on the wheel something the
Crowsnest someone drinking someone
flying into that is that we want players
to encounter like different player types
right everyone's different in one place
if only everyone has a kind of part of
the ship that I tend to go to the crow's
nest a lot I know you tend to take the
wheel yeah so we're just Saints people
like you know come to see our thieves
calm forward session cider and just sign
up and join us in our technical alpha
because we have a hundred thousand
people playing this week right and
that's just to make clear so I'm from
Tuesday to Saturday during games when we
call players at home in the technical
are all going to be playing cross play
together the first time so okay what's
one of the funniest things that you've
seen in the world because there are some
crazy I think it's the creativity of
what people do with the tools we give
them so like I was playing with some
strangers in our alpha and one I was
playing with the instrument and somebody
started using a spade is like a
percussion instrument hitting it on the
floor of the deck and you can hit
different parts and and it was just
amazing I've started seeing more and
more players doing this in the community
now oh yeah so it's just like thing yeah
it's what people do with the tools about
brand new features to Gamescom and one
of the new features is you can now be
sick in a bucket and then use that
bucket on other people really practical
puke it's an important feature like
[Laughter]
blinded and then you get your Cutlass
out come and join us inside we got two
hundred fifty thousand plus more more
than that now you'll probably be ticking
up and right as we speak
everybody will get a chance to play the
game prior to release as well if you're
in an Insider everyone that's our
commitment to the Emmys and you can be
sick in a bucket and everyone will love
you for it
unlike a house party everyone we've got
loads of exclusives our big news to come
so stay tuned but